près de rodez un berger doit faire
traverser la voie ferrée à ses 600
moutons pour accéder à ces prêts
malheureusement la sncf a supprimé
depuis peu le poste de garde barrière et
le troupeau court maintenant de grands
risques d'autant que la sncf refuse
obstinément de communiqué les horaires
de passage des trains le merger n'ai pas
comparé 600 moutons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
passé en 25 secondes c'est pas possible
il faut deux minutes pour que le tour
passe
[Applaudissements]
alors j'ai écrit partout du conseil
général peu d'âme la république tout le
monde s'en fout dans le seul moyenne
c'est d'aller en haut lieu pour se faire
entendre
j'étais à paris pour un problème c'est
le chef passage à niveau j'espère ne pas
être monté à paris pour épauler lotoko
gspr on prend des risques car il suffit
qu'ils arrivent une voiture à véria qui
klaxonnent loto pour pousse et c'est on
se fait happer par
il en veut à la sncf
pourquoi parceque il a demandé 100 fois
que l'on prête attention à son troupeau
qui doit traverser la voie de chemin de
fer qui doit emprunter un passage et
jamais 1 116 a tenu compte de ce qu'il
demandait qui était peu de choses pour
finir ce qu'ils soient prévenus un peu à
l'avant ce que le train va arriver c'est
peu de chose miss earth un monument
administratif démissionne c'était pour
pas les asem siècle si j'avais eu le
talent jaur évoqué les problèmes
l'éleveur de moncton aussi qu'ils sont
pas peu dire
[Applaudissements]
autre choix n'avait que 30 moto mais on
n'avait pas les investissements
d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
celui qui investit 10 ports est celui
qui a mené ce type a et il avance à
reculons
aujourd'hui j'ai reçu la réponse du
président de la république je lui avais
écrit le 22 octobre il m'a répondu
aujourd'hui
né le 21 ème mois presque alors mené à
bien une caisse qui qu'est ce qui va en
sortir
le député jacques godfrain aussi
intervenus bon alors on verra bien
jusqu'à présent rien n'a été fait encore
bon j'espère que ça va bouger ou alors
on emploie les grands moyens
actuellement nous avons des pressions
[Musique]
sur les coûts l'antenne l'écho des
courges ajusterait que nos élus en
particulier gouvernement veuille guen se
référer à la devise de notre ancien
ministre sully qui disait pâturages et
labos sont les deux mamelles de la
france
et bien aujourd'hui on peut lire que
chômage
jassem et quotas sont les vertus de
l'europe
[Applaudissements]
ab on se bat comme on peut mais ça a été
j'avais vu que j'étais devant le monde
applaudit ça fait que j'ai pas dis des
bêtises et et ce qui m'a touché le plus
je vous le dirai c'est à la sortie de la
maison de la radio
l'âge la foule de jeunes qui m'attendait
pour moi pour me féliciter
en me disant que j'avais osé dire haut
ce que beaucoup pensent étoiles
seulement demandé même à signer des
autographes
je n'ai signé le 21 mai c'est pour lire
peur dans mes paroles par l espoir pour
l'avenir
je ne connais pas capable de fournir une
politique actuelle en france lorsque je
regrette voyait au passage c'est qu'on
soit obligé de mettre à l'écran devant
des millions de téléspectateurs en cas
qui aurait pu être résolu par
l'intelligence de quelques-uns à limite
la télévision devient le dernier recours
pour des cas comme celui là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un lieu personne est ce que le thème des
retraites est réparti à nu ce s'il vous
plaît
voilà voilà le passage qu'on nous
proposait de passer avec les moutons
c'est inadmissible car ça nous allons
jde 950 mètres et et nous obligent à
suivre l'axé première année sur deux ça
m a imaginé un tout pour 2 600 650
produits à les voitures qui passent sur
cette route
ce que nous demandons c'est d'être
prévenus trois minutes minimum voire par
le passage du train le jour y aura en
effet se produire un jour si rien n'est
fait la tenue 22,5 vingtaine appartenait
pas tarifs que nous ne pouvons plus le
supporter je prenne ce qui n'est pas
encore une time spécial et lui assène
nommé samedi ou alors il ya une place à
se tourner c'est notre 6e ça doit bouger
jeu thomas bien photothèque se battre
sinon on passera vite enterré
[Musique]
un vrai paquet de problèmes que les
moutons et les huiles c'est pas un homme
ordinaire qu'il résoudra moi je vois pas
c'est chercher cinq pattes un mouton que
cette histoire faudrait un berger hors
du commun un berger avec un grand b le
président de la république boni déduit
have a écrit il est habitué aux horaires
des échéances au retard des dossiers
onze enquêtes supplémentaires
un train d'enfer qui mène à conduire le
grand entrepôt sur la voie nationale et
il a mis du temps à répond ça c'est bon
signe c'est qu'il a réfléchi
bon c'est pas tout ça renault à nos
moutons comme disait ma mère je sais
plus qui
[Musique]